Imagine you're in a game show with three doors.
One has a car, and the others have goats.
You pick a door, say #1, and the host reveals
a goat behind another door, #3. They ask if
you want to switch your choice to door #2.
So, do you switch?
Most people think it doesn’t matter whether
you switch or not.
But switching increases your chances of winning.
Initially, your chosen door has a ⅓ chance
of winning, while the other doors together
have a ⅔ chance. The host reveals a losing
door, so they’re filtering out the bad choice,
leaving the other door with a ⅔ chance of
winning.
It’s easier to understand if there are 100
doors.
Your initial choice has a 1/100 chance of
winning, while the other doors have a 99/100
chance.
The host then filters out the options for
you by eliminating 98 bad doors they know
don't have the prize.
This leaves the remaining door with the rest
of the odds, a 99/100 chance of having the
prize.